-So, guys, we are smack in
the middle of March Madness.
And every year, we pick a team
to root for,
and this year,
we picked Gonzaga, okay?
So we gave out these rowdy rags
to all the students that are
following the team around, okay?
And what we want them to do is,
at a certain point,
just stand up
and start whipping them around
and do something, you know,
something crazy.
And so far, it's worked.
They've won the last two games.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
I'm just saying.
They were nail-biters,
but they did win.
-Yes.
-Yeah, so now they're playing
tomorrow.
They're playing
the Arkansas Razorbacks.
-Uh-oh.
[ Light cheering ]
-No. No.
We have to -- We have to --
I mean, I love them,
I hope they do well.
-Yeah, but not too well.
-Not too well, yeah, exactly.
We want to help Gonzaga
win again, okay?
But I think we should
switch it up.
'Cause right now,
we want 'em to sing like,
"I'll tell you what I want,
what I really really want."
Yeah, I'm changing that up.
-What?
-Basically,
here's what we want them to do.
Each half is 20 minutes, right?
So when the game clock
goes down to 11:35 --
that's when
"The Tonight Show" airs --
I want everyone to stand up
and just take their rowdy rags
and whip it around.
But I want to -- Since they're
playing the Arkansas Razorbacks,
I think they should go...
♪ Let's beat the Razorbacks,
Razorbacks, Razorbacks ♪
♪ We'll beat
the Razorback kids ♪
♪ Beat the Razorback kids ♪
♪ Beat Arkansas ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're laughing.
What are you laughing at?
-That seems like a lot.
-Wait, wait.
You think that the students --
-And the harmonies? You want 'em
to get the harmonies in there?
-You think the kids
won't stand up at 11:35 --
-Oh, no. They will.
I'm not saying they won't.
But I don't think
it'll sound like that.
[ Laughter ]
-It might be too tricky.
So at 11:20 -- 11:35...
-11:35.
-...definitely 11:35 --
stand up, and what I would like
you to try, again, if we can --
Can we see if we can do it?
All right. And the Arkansas fan,
you don't have to do it.
You can sit in quiet protest.
One, two...
♪ Let's beat the Razorbacks,
Razorbacks, Razorbacks ♪
♪ We'll beat
the Razorback kids ♪
Stop. Just stop, stop,
stop, stop, stop.
Absolutely no.
It's a disaster.
It's a complete disaster.
-Well, it's a high harmony.
-It's a complete disaster.
-Get rid of that high harmony.
-They're never going to do it.
-Right.
And somebody's gonna have to
yell, "One, two, three."
You know what I mean?
-That's it?
-Well, just go -- Yeah.
-Oh, that's pretty good.
They'll have to stand up and go,
"One, two, three,"
and don't say anything.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. And then quiet.
-Right.
-All right, so at 11:35 --
I'm changing it up.
-Boom. So at 11:35 -- 11:34.
-So when it goes down
to 11:40 tonight --
Oh, here it comes down to
11:37, 11:36, 11:35,
you go, "One, two, three!"
-Boom.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay. That's what they'll do.
-There you go.
-Forget about the other one.
It's too confusing. I apologize.
I apologize. That was --
Yeah, why would --
-It was good heart.
-It's tomorrow night.
It's tomorrow night
they're playing.
-What time?
-You got to check
your local listings.
-Okay.
-I think tomorrow --
Do we know what time they play?
-7:00.
-7:00
on the dot.
-Ooh.
-But "at 7:00"
doesn't mean anything to me,
'cause it's when the clock
goes down to 11:35 --
-Each...?
-Each half.
-Yes.
-You got two opportunities.
for the students.
If you're rooting
for your team --
Gonzaga -- if you're rooting
for the Bulldogs,
I want you to go...
at 11:36, 11:35,
"One, two, three!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey...
-Look at your phone.
-Yeah, look at your phone.
-Look at your phone or
something, do whatever you want.
-Check your message, like,
check for your keys.
-Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
That's what I want.
-And then imaginarily
talk to somebody.
-And go Zags.
Go Zags, everybody.
We got this. Come on.
We got this.
Sweet 16, baby.